hey friends so I'm going to get to the
conclusion of this out of the way at the
starch there will not be a POI top 10
list this year in fact
um I think that I'm calling it on this
project in general
uh but to understand why I'm gonna do
one of my patented walk and talks here
so come along with me while uh I go get
in some dance practice here yeah Drex
here from drexfacture POI sharing with
you the love of hoi spinning and flow
Arts to benefit your body and brain and
uh today we're talking about one of
those things that I've done to share my
love of poi spinning over the years that
I think has run its course but before we
dive in I just want to give a quick
shout out to the Friends of the channel
big thanks to dark monk fire Mecca flow
fests flow toys juggling calling pyro
Terra light toys spin balls and Ultra
POI for helping to make the videos on
this channel possible you can learn more
about all these amazing businesses and
what they're doing to support flow
artists like yourself by checking out
the links that I've got down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to non-business friends of the
channel Johnny Howard Lane machinsky and
Becca becklinen thank you all so very
much for your support from my work and
my mission so I think it's officially
safe to say that winter has come to DC
we saw the temperatures drop down into
the 30s this past week
um and uh shall we say I am not good
about handling the colds
um but still so I recently got back from
a trip to Salt Lake City and one of
those things that uh kind of came out of
that trip for me was realizing just how
important it is to me to get in like a
lot of physical activity
so
um I'm trying to get out and do some
dance today I sometimes allow myself to
get so wrapped up in writing or editing
that I miss out on this and goodness
knows it's not exactly easy when uh the
weather is this frightful but um
I'm gonna try and do it nonetheless
today okay so the POI top 10 list
um
it started up in 2012.
um and originally
it was uh me looking at the work of uh a
British juggler
by name of Luke Burridge
I thought his idea of like a top 40
jugglers list was pretty cool and uh I
noticed that a couple boy Spinners were
talking about trying to get a spot on
this
and in my mind it seemed kind of silly
for us to be asking for a ticket to
somebody else's party
so I figured hey what if I create my own
and even right away there's a lot of
controversy around this
a lot of people told me that they
believed that creating that list was
damaging the community in many ways by
uh essentially creating another way by
which people could puff up their egos
and uh also too that it seemed rather
telling that the list was consistently
dominated by uh CIS hat white guys from
the United States and uh not gonna lie a
lot of them actually had a point you
know just in terms of community impact
over the years
I started getting some really disturbing
reports that some of the people who
wound up on the list would then
sometimes turn around and use that
notoriety to kind of be really
unpleasant to others I remember hearing
of uh one incident in particular where
somebody who made her on the top 10 list
I got really drunk at a festival and
when the uh when the staff there tried
to get him to calm down he blew up at
them with
the statement do you know who I am
um which
anytime that's coming out of somebody's
mouth something has definitely gone
wrong I also heard at least one story of
somebody who made the list kind of being
bullied for it with you know people they
encounter being like oh so you think
you're hot stuff now right
I really wanted to for many years
believe that there were still a lot of
positives that would come out of it in
terms of just like charting the
evolution of uh the art form over the
years
and so there were times when I admit I
tried really hard to kind of
um
to
convince myself that those positives
outweighed the negatives and not pay as
much attention to them probably both to
the detriment of myself as well as to
others and you know it has to be said on
my end of things that doing that list of
year was actually really really
stressful for me
you know not just because of the
reaction that it would engender from
people
but also because like I had to compile a
whole bunch of footage I had to count up
the votes
this process took quite a long time and
it always meant that like the end of the
year was a really stressful time for me
when I was struggling to get all this
done there were many times when
you know people would ask or demand that
I add more spots to the list to include
more spinners
and I'd be like look if I do that it's
going to take me twice as long to edit
this video so it's either I get help
or like
y'all start make stop making these
demands of me and more often than not
the response I got from that was not oh
I will help you it was well I think that
you should change your uh your editing
process to uh so that I don't have to
help you out which yeah that was that
was not terribly helpful on a lot of
levels and you know a lot of this
culminated in a year where
there were some people that made the
list that
um that got recognized on it
that
have made people in our community feel
very very very uncomfortable in the
community
um and that was kind of my wake-up call
that it was time to switch gears and it
was time to try to make the list be more
than just like who were the American
white dudes who everybody's been
watching this year
um
and I'm really proud of what came out of
that honestly the year that I created
that committee and I like basically
treated it like an award show
I think that that is the finest top 10
list that I have ever done and it was
also by an enormous margin the most work
I had to work around a lot of people's
schedules and
um you know it was really stressful
getting the uh the acceptance speeches
from people I gave people like 48 hours
to do that in and I cannot believe that
I managed to get one from everybody
it was a great video but like that
process was just not sustainable so I'll
be real with you the next year when
interest around it
kind of ebbed a little bit and I didn't
get as many submissions for nominations
wasn't actually very disappointed in
that
you know
sure I think that it is good for us to
recognize
people that accomplish a lot in the
community I think that it's good for us
to be able to track how the community
evolves over time
and also too just to be able to tell
people hey you know the stuff that you
did had an impact on me and it was
awesome
um if for no other reason then I think a
lot of people just don't actually know
how big an impact they can have and it's
always good to uh to be able to show
people that they're uh
their their actions can sometimes have a
bigger
footprint in the world than they think
it does
but at the same time like
yeah it really was kind of nice going
through the holidays without having the
top 10 list hanging over my head
it was kind of nice not to have to
juggle a bunch of schedules it was kind
of nice not to spend the holidays on my
laptop editing together this gigantic
compilation video
kind of nice to actually just kids who
enjoy that period
leading up to the new year it had been
nearly a decade since I'd been able to
do that
and it was kind of nice so every single
November for the past 11 years I've sat
myself down to think okay do I really
want to do this to myself again and you
know in a lot of cases I'd have people
that would be asking me about it that
would be like hitting me up and be like
hey you can do the top 10 again this
year hey you're going to do the top 10
again this year
and that would put me in a place of
thinking well okay I guess this actually
means something to people maybe I should
and
that's notably tapered off a lot in the
past couple years
and without that kind of enthusiasm
coming in I'm realizing that you know my
natural state is kind of just to say nah
I just want to kind of enjoy the
holidays you know so I have actually
known now for several months that I
wasn't going to come back and do the top
10 list and um
you know I uh I tried making a video
about this once before actually and I
got really really into the Weeds on a
different topic that I will probably
make a video about at some point but
that doesn't really belong in this video
so yeah
the POI top 10 video it's a project that
I did for a decade
and that I think ran its course
and now I'm ready to move on and do
something else with my life and I'm sure
that there's a lot of people out there
that feel a lot of nostalgia for that
project that you know are going to be
angry with me for bannoning it and
telling me that like am I not doing it
again is somehow failing to support the
broader Community or give people access
to my platform
and I mean they're free to that opinion
they've never helped me out the editing
they've never helped me out with uh
trying to navigate all this stuff so
you know hey if you want to see it
happen you can be the one to do it right
and I think it does also need to be
inserted here too that you know
one of the big things that went wrong
with that list over the years and that I
think a lot of people watching it
considered to be a feature rather than a
bug
was that really it just became
a list of people who all looked and spun
very much like each other
you know it it's hard to miss the fact
that like I've had a conversation with
several people in the past year about
how very frequently our idea of what
makes great literature
is actually just a bunch of old white
dudes sitting around talking about stuff
written by other old white dudes because
it speaks to them and their experiences
and I think to a certain extent the POI
top 10 list became that
it became this way of
a bunch of young dudes in the POI worlds
reflecting themselves back at themselves
and telling them that this was great
and I
I feel bad that that is part of the
legacy of having worked on this project
because it wasn't what I wanted to do
when I started out and uh
you know I should have paid more
attention I should have listened to more
people as it was going on
and that's on me and I'm sorry
and you know it it is absolutely
inevitable I I fully grok that by not
doing the top 10 list by announcing that
I'm not doing it and I will never do it
again
that it means that almost certainly
somebody else is going to try and step
in and create their own version of it
and they're gonna have to deal with that
Pitfall and I guarantee you
there's a very very very good chance
that the person that does that
will likewise view it as a feature
instead of a bug
that it tends to be a space in which
young dudes in the community reflect
themselves back at themselves and think
that that then implies greatness or it
could be that somebody else comes along
who just cracks the code in a way that I
never could and you know what I will be
first in line to congratulate them if
that does happen
so if you feel like you're up to the
challenge I invite you to do it and for
my part I eagerly look forward to having
a stress-free holiday that's going to be
amazing I'll probably still do something
to cap off the year we'll see what it
looks like but um I can tell you it
won't be a list of top 10 POI Spinners
and I think that that is for the best
both for me as well as for this
community so
play top 10 list
R.I.P y'all
uh have a good one and uh see on
Wednesday for a new video yeah
[Music]
this year video would not be possible if
not for the wonderful support of all of
these nice people right here these are
my flow patrons on patreon they and the
people who sit down in the description
help to make this video and all the
videos on this channel possible thank
you one and all so very much for your
amazing support
um if you're out there watching and
you'd like to support this work that I'm
doing bringing POI spinning and flow
Arts to The Wider world and helping
people connect with their brains and
their bodies you can do that by heading
on over to patreon.com
directly and signing up there you can
get access to a whole bunch of awesome
rewards as well as helping me out in
that mission so go please check that out
thank you in advance and if you'd like
to see more of my Vlogs I will include a
link to a playlist of them down in the
description as well as up here on screen
if you are watching on YouTube also the
YouTube algorithm thinks that you'll
like this top video right here so maybe
give that a look see as well
um I'm gonna try and go dance now it is
like what 30 degrees out and windy so
we'll see how long I last but uh keep
your fingers crossed for me there
friends and uh
yeah as it stands I am uh looking at
shooting a video of some dance stuff
that I've been doing real soon so be on
the lookout for that uh I hope that uh I
I hope that
it comes out okay with the weather as it
is anyway have a good one and I'll see
you next time peace